ah
comigo o mundo em que a vencerem recebem
máscaras
ela já não há escolas com máscaras a
trabalhar com máscaras criança família
campanhas em ordem e só acabam
conhecendo novas pessoas
depois da morte de cabelo ao ok então
neste mundo
não sabemos quem é quem identifica
mudanças pelo novo estatuto mas não
temos
não temos a imagem da pessoa
não conhecemos a cara gostou e só com
esse só temos a oportunidade de ver
quando deus chama as pessoas né
neste mundo existe um rapaz chamado
dinheiro e o dinho tem um sonho quieto e
será só para trocar o seu rosto
a linha pode ser qualquer uma dessas
sessões op você leu
pode ser que vocês vocês não com ela e
toda noite e dorme a sonhar é ver o seu
rosto até o dia que ela vai o espelho ea
primeira a levantar sua mágica e
descobre que ele é um cara é muito
bonito como algumas só está aqui dentro
é preciso que a pessoa não quer ser
atingido ele faz uma descoberta
interessante à venda um estranho que
seja acordado eu quero partilhar isso
com mas tem medo
mesmo assim eu dar um passo mais ninguém
deu apresentam e em se revelar a sua
cara
tudo todas as outras torcidas está neste
mundo mascaradas começa começaram a
final da tarde assim que o normal é
diferente estou só depois de morrerem
quando só quando ver as máscaras não
podia precisar buscar as citações opções
carrão assim a então ela convida estou a
ficar a pensar fora da caixa mas que
está fora da caixa pra explicar uma
ajudinha quer que até um ponto
interessante é que ele quer que estas
percebam que todo mundo de vela da caixa
e muitos até fora da caixa
mas quantos destes bem fora
neste mundo temos muitas pessoas presas
há limites dias em que ninguém disse que
eles não podiam ultrapassar as linhas
então quem serve de motivação para
convidar as pessoas a viverem fora da
caixa e não pensar fora da caixa
o diminuto toco muitas muitas destes
indivíduos morrem focados pelas máscaras
muitos deles morrem sem conhecerem a sua
realidade onde se mora em um sonho e eu
volto a dizer a vida sã que se deva
cuidado e desta forma se alguém ficou
com essa história eu queria convidar
esta pessoa a tirar a máscara
nós vivemos num mundo em que temos mais
caras mais sofisticadas
elas ganharam do nosso rosto o traste
que não dá para perceber o que realmente
existe por trás da máscara a acredito
que somos muitos aqui que em algum
momento quiseram revelar um rosto bonito
é que tem uma dessas maneiras e por
causa da estréia foi possível mas que
achava que isto era o certo
o novo verdão sonha em ficar acordada
nós podemos sonhar então vamos
concretizar disse o tenente
então fica o convite pra vocês terão as
botas máscaras
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]